the nightlife in italy is famous
worldwide when the sun goes down its
cities come alive with locals and
tourists alike looking to party have fun
and sometimes even get a little rowdy
but in an unknown town in italy there is
a nightclub that offers a very different
experience for those who wander in they
might find themselves playing a role in
a drama far more exciting and dangerous
than the night out they expected to the
outside viewer
scp-453 is nothing out of the ordinary
just a standard nightclub filled with
partygoers and revelers evening after
evening as typical as it may seem the
unassuming nature of the venue is
nothing short of intentional by design
it is actually a front owned and
operated by foundation personnel who
carefully monitor everyone who comes in
and out keeping a watchful eye for any
indication of drama or danger violence
can and will erupt at any moment and no
matter what no night at the club is ever
routine but the visitors chaotic actions
are not their own though the people's
decision to attend the club is of their
own free will after some time settling
into the environment something changes
over the course of the night people
begin to do things that may otherwise
seem out of character for them in fact
they are playing roles though the same
roles are played each evening they are
played by different people night after
night some of these dramas are harmless
but some are violent and some may even
be world threatening if the partygoers
survive their role in their scripts they
will then leave the club and return home
with only a faint memory of the events
they took part in that evening the next
night the process renews and the events
will repeat but not all scripts repeat
at the same frequency some are regular
while others are only triggered by
special circumstances only select people
take part in these scripts while the
others around them go about their night
until triggered to take on a role and
these bizarre performances may have been
going on for a very long time the
building now known as
scp-453 may have existed in some form or
another even before the foundation
existed with investigations of the site
indicating that it was once a villa of a
powerful roman senator who held
extensive parties every night these
pervasive affairs the odd happenings
that occurred during them may have left
a lasting imprint because no matter what
is built on the site it seems as though
people are attracted to the building to
party the foundation has had possession
of the site for a long time and in a
previous attempt to neutralize its
chaotic power they even went as far as
demolishing it completely to the ground
but that still proved ineffective even
when there was no villa or nightclub
present large groups of revelers would
still gather the gatherings would turn
into street parties the street parties
in two riots many times these
circumstances were cause for even worse
consequences than the regular series of
events the foundation didn't know how to
stop the scripted nightclub but they
could maybe control it if the people
wanted a nightclub the foundation would
give them one the site was rebuilt from
scratch and from the outside looking in
had all the characteristics of your
standard everyday disco watering hole
but really it was meticulously
constructed to be a sophisticated scp
facility capable of handling whatever
anomalous activity was thrown at it
built from the same materials used in
all other scp containment sites and
always staffed with containment
personnel on high alert ready to handle
the more violent and dangerous scripts
that may play out at any moment but
control over the scripted nightclub may
be more easily said than done the
nightclub has been in operation for a
long time and over the years the staff
has noticed some extremely odd events
taking place for instance certain things
aren't always where they're supposed to
be aspects of the club are built and
then slowly shifted to new locations
within the site over time most notable
the weapons locker on site for staff to
suppress violent incidents has slowly
been drifting towards the men's restroom
and away from the secured section for
staff only and it's not the only part of
the building slowly shuffling its way
about could
scp-453 be learning to foil the
foundation and if so why while many of
the scripts that play out in the
nightclub are harmless some are of more
concern the foundation has been studying
what triggers different scripts and
while some seem to inevitably play out
and pull people in others are triggered
by the presence of different guests the
silver harlequins will only play out if
more than 15 guests are over the age of
60 but there are few distinct
characteristics of the scripts all begin
at approximately 9 pm at night and while
people continue behaving in modern ways
there is one key difference all scripted
dialogue takes place entirely in latin
the foundation believes that these
scripts may be playing out events that
happened in the initial incarnations of
the club back in roman times while the
players differ the events always remain
the same and while the scripts rotate
scp-453
seems to gravitate towards three scripts
all posing unique challenges for the
foundation and one posing a potential
end of the world scenario first up
script 43 the cheating wife this is
normally the most common script and
poses a relatively small threat to those
not actively engaged in the script or
outside the nightclub the main priority
is to have the staff's medical team on
site and ready to intervene when things
get bloody it begins at 9 49 pm when a
young woman heads to the men's bathroom
she will be followed by three men the
events of the bathroom are expunged but
a little over an hour later a fourth
male will enter the picture it's the
husband of the woman and he's not happy
he will enter the nightclub order a
bottle of red wine and head to the
bathroom there he will brutally assault
the three men knocking all three
unconscious and causing minor brain
trauma to the third he will then drag
his wife out of the restroom cursing her
and accusing her of infidelity as he
takes her out of the nightclub the
script then terminates and all
participants no longer remember the
events beyond a bar fight medical
attention is recommended for the three
men and the woman especially the most
severely injured of the men but after
the script concludes strange events
continue to happen while none of the
participants know each other before the
script begins and don't maintain memory
of the exact events they display strange
behavior the man playing the husband
becomes violent when questioned and
develops an obsession with a woman
playing his wife the foundation believes
it wise to keep these two individuals
separated oddly
scp-453 seems to prefer men who are
shorter and less physically strong than
the other men to play the husband
attempts to short-circuit the script
have proved unsuccessful only delaying
it an attempt to remove the weapon a
wine bottle has led to the husband using
more dangerous weapons like a bar stool
instead which can lead to fatalities it
seems that scp-453 gets what it wants
and what it wants is for the show to go
on then there is script 21 the senator's
visit this is considered a higher
priority script and the foundation knows
to be on high alert for medical
intervention to prevent fatalities this
one kicks off at 10 13 pm as the
civilian steps into the club and takes
the role of the senator the original
owner of the villa he is accompanied by
an entourage of 13 servants each
carrying improvised weapons and when
they step in the club stops dead in
anticipation of the coming events
because two people in the club just
became assassins the senator and his
servants take over a table and the
senator begins ordering extravagant food
and drinks he'll always gravitate
towards the most expensive items
available from the current stock and his
orders are always completed at specific
times no matter how the foundation tries
to intervene during his meal a civilian
selected to be an activist will approach
the senator and begin criticizing the
treatment of the citizens in a nearby
city only to be assaulted brutally by
three members of the entourage the
foundation will take her away from
medical treatment after she's left for
dead if you think that's brutal be
prepared because the senator's night is
about to get a whole lot more dangerous
the first of two assassins will then
approach the senator pull a blade and
attack him the assassin will be
intercepted by four servants who will
kill him despite the best efforts of
foundation personnel to prevent the
outcome but it's the second assassin who
is a far greater concern he will incite
a brawl among civilians around the
eastern wall of the club then use the
chaos to attack seven of the servants as
he approaches the senator those servants
are of priority for medical intervention
but the chaos makes it impossible to
intercept them until 10 minutes after
midnight the assassin will then engage
with the remaining servants barely
surviving and eventually stab the
senator in the neck fatally the
foundation has been unable to prevent
this and the danger isn't over yet the
fight at the nightclub will continue to
escalate causing more injuries but no
more fatalities until over an hour has
passed and 19 civilians take on the role
of roman guards they'll pacify the crowd
and clear the club this is when the
foundation can finally intervene and
treat the wounded much like the first
smaller scale script any attempts to
interrupt the flow of the events taking
place will be unsuccessful and often
result in more deaths none of the large
number of participants remember the
events only believing they were in a
brutal bar fight this is one of the most
common scripts and the foundation's only
priority is to try to minimize
casualties with quick medical
intervention but one script hints at a
much darker event at the club and that's
script 82 the plurality cult most
scripts begin before midnight and
plunged the club into chaos but if no
script has started before then and the
club seems mundane the foundation knows
to get ready they'll suit up in riot
gear designed to withstand neurotoxins
and claim to the guests that this is
part of a theme night at roughly two
hours after midnight the events will
begin with one civilian standing in the
center of the room saying the time of
plurality has come at least half of the
other civilians will then join in saying
we embrace the many but there is
something different about this script
sometimes foundation staff members will
join in
this is the most dangerous script at
scp-453
and staff knows to immediately terminate
to any foundation member who has been
converted because intervention
453-82 pariah is about to begin and
there is no room for error first any
civilians who did not become engaged in
the cold should be immediately evacuated
to a safe holding area if possible the
priority then turns to subduing the
cultists by any means necessary the
security team should attempt to restrain
them and keep them alive but lethal
force may be necessary the cultists have
a priority of their own though they will
not respond to any attacks by the
security team and will instead begin a
latin chant that ends with their leader
laughing hysterically and offering a
toast to the club the club will
seemingly return to normal but the
danger is just beginning before 2 25 am
all the cultists and all civilians must
be removed from the premises by any
means necessary if other attempts have
failed the foundation will release type
14 neurotoxic gas into the club to
eliminate anyone on site with one
exception the cult leader is not to be
harmed under any circumstances if the
cult leader is harmed in any way or the
staff has not subdued the cult by 2 30
am the foundation will trigger a
self-destruct mechanism that will
eliminate the threat for now the site's
unique properties cannot be stopped but
the script can be stopped in its tracks
the clock cannot be allowed to reach 3am
under any circumstances more worrisome
this script is becoming more and more
frequent the cycle continues but the
foundation is focused on containment the
club is to be staffed at all times by
bartenders bouncers cleaners and
emergency and medical staff as well as
at least 10 security staff members and
two observation personnel all are
responsible for studying and memorizing
the scripts and being prepared to handle
any scripted events that occur the site
is to be inspected and measured
regularly for any changes and to make
sure all its security measures are in
working order the site will be locked
every day between 4 am and 8pm to
prepare for the night ahead because at
8pm on the dot
scp-453 opens for business
seeking new players for its drama of the
night for another unpredictable building
check out scp-3008 trapped in ikea or
watch
scp-701 the hanged king's tragedy for
another unconventional drama